a lot of looming questions over what
happens next as far as stimulus for the
american people struggling during this
pandemic
you've got the dow up 315 points on two
things
hope over a corona virus vaccine and
that
congress will get together and get
something done larry kudlow can give us
an update he's the white house economic
advisor
larry what can you tell us this morning
there seems to be optimism
on wall street uh is something getting
done
well look i think i agree with the
vaccine although we can't
necessarily verify russia as reagan used
to say trust but verify
however i would add the president's
presser
saturday night where he announced the
executive orders
really helped the market roar yesterday
was up over 350 points
and i think that's continuing today
we've had also
good numbers uh on jobs just
i mean great numbers on the jobs report
last friday but even more good numbers
yesterday
and this morning nfib small business
confidence
was down a tad but it's still holding a
very high level
so the economy looks good and i think
the president has given
a lot of important assistance to the
unemployed
and pro-growth measures to those who are
working
and those who want to go back to work i
think that's helping the story but are
we talking about the best
option larry fox news is reporting this
morning we just had our own chad
pergamon
reporting that there's virtually been no
communication between the white house
and congressional
leaders since the discussion discussion
seized friday afternoon
can you tell us anything has changed on
that front
well what i can say is as the president
said yesterday
as secretary mnuchin said we're willing
to negotiate
we are willing to sit down as long as
it's a serious
negotiation thus far it has not been
serious
the numbers democratic numbers are way
too high we are not going to just split
the difference
um meanwhile if you look at their plan
sandra
the a third of it has nothing to do with
kovi
okay it has to do with mail-in votes and
harvesting votes
and letting felons out of jail and
things of that sort had nothing to do
with covet and that needs to be stripped
out that's democratic left-wing
wish list take that out chop their
number down
look there's stuff we would like we
would love to extend the
payroll protection for small business we
would like that very much
we want very much to be able to put
additional money in
for safe and secure school openings
um the president is still open uh to
direct mailing of checks
of twelve hundred dollars per person
those are things that we could
talk about more than willing to but the
democrats have to change their views
and they've got to be you know show us
it's a serious matter
okay mcconnell is saying that the
democrats blocked this coronavirus
legislation
he says that the press is covering it
like quote like another routine
political standoff
i'll get your description of this moment
in just a second but first here's chuck
schumer
reacting to the executive
action president trump's executive order
on unemployment benefits is put together
in such a sloppy way
that it'll take weeks or months for
states to even implement
millions could lose everything before
they ever see a check republicans must
get back to the negotiating table
respond to that larry and under this
plan laid out by the president would
when would americans see that check well
two points first of all
we put up gop sarah mcconnell put up
short-term extensions of unemployment
and the democrats blocked it at least
twice
so it's kind of silly to say well it's
going to take a long time they could
have gotten that done
a week or 10 days ago second point the
states are in position
to increase the unemployment benefits
remember
the six hundred dollar plus up that came
out of cares in march
was administered by the states with the
help of
the labor department the labor
department has put out
a number of circulars already saying
they will go and help the states in any
way possible
this is not that hard we put out a
formula all right let me try to get this
straight because some people
on sunday weren't listening to what we
said or whatever
the states first of all if they give a
hundred dollars already
in benefits just a hundred any state
gives a hundred
they will qualify for the 300
federal plus up okay the states will do
it but the federal government will put a
three hundred dollars
wait that's a big statement that's a big
statement the states will do it have you
canvassed those states to make sure that
they can
afford it and be are we modified
slightly the mechanics of the deal
so initially and states can still if
they put another hundred dollars in
to raise the benefit more generously
that's fine it's up to them but
the way we're leaving it now is any
state
who put in a hundred dollars before for
unemployment benefits and
every state did they will then qualify
for the extra three hundred dollars so
the baseline
of unemployment uh benefits from states
is
roughly 400 dollars
okay per person per week that's the
median
on top of that the federal government is
going to put in
300 so that will give the benefit
overall
of 700 that's a tremendous
there are 16 million people unemployed
they need help but
they need assistance and we stand to
give it to them i've only got a minute
left i think the question is can
can they afford it are they willing to
do it the april i'm saying they've
already done it they've already done it
sandra in other words
they've already addressed this real
quickly though this is this is governor
cuomo from new york
uh and the arkansas governor hutchinson
national governors association they put
out this statement they said we
appreciate the white house proposals to
provide additional solutions to address
the challenges
however we're concerned by the
significant administrative burdens and
costs the latest action would place on
the states
address their concerns in reaction
both friends of mine we will work with
them if there's any complications
i think their states have done are fine
they've already
changed their programs to meet the cares
demand
or the care's generosity from last march
so they're already on their way
we're estimating it'll take about two
weeks to get the checks out
the benefits out it will be administered
by the states let me repeat this
it's going to be 700. per person per
week
that's a very big number second let's
not forget
president's payroll tax deferral which
will be
a wage hike for middle-class
americans a wage hike of roughly eleven
hundred dollars to the 140 million
people
who are heroes they've been able to work
and they have
so we're helping the 16 million
unemployed we are helping the 140
million
who are working uh we want to provide uh
more
incentives to work and come back to work
and for those who are not employed
if they look at these numbers an 1100
pay high 1100 pay hike
is an incentive for them to come back to
work so these are
crucial items to assist to help to grow
the economy
and i think that's a big reason these
are big reasons why the stock market
is feeling so darn good it is up 300
points this morning the dow
topping 28 000 for the first time since
february we're watching that larry i
know you've got a busy day of meetings
and a lot of decisions to make we
appreciate the update thank you
thank you sandra